it wouldn't be a mega makeover hour
without a mega makeover secret all right
our dream team member charlotte tilbury
is backstage with some beauty tips
charlotte
hi darling drew it's charlotte tilbury
here i can't wait to share my beauty
secrets with you so i'm going to show
you how to resize and reshape your lips
to make it look really neutral and
universally flattering it's really
important to get the right lip liner and
the lipstick that match
smile for me my darling answer gorgeous
you can really get the perfect lip
powder
so this will keep your lipstick
perfectly in place and it will set it's
a waterproof lip liner
[Music]
now i'm going to use pillow talking text
smiles when we're done
so my darling angela what do you think
it looks great perfect we wear that
every day every single day i love this
so darling i'm going to show you how to
get a hollywood contour literally in
seconds by using my airbrush bronzing
powder underneath the jawline that lifts
the jawline
suck in your cheeks
follow the hollow underneath
your cheekbones and then in a circle
over the forehead and you go down the
side of the nose down the side of the
nose and then underneath
look in the mirror forming my garlic
wow
oh yeah that's gorgeous you've got
gorgeous cheekbones
now i do no you do
darling drew thank you so much thank you
[Music]
and i am so grateful to charlotte to be
able to say that our audience is going
home with charlotte's magic cream today
now this
is every best of beauty awards winner
you guys are literally going home with
one of the finest products on the planet
thank you charlotte
[Music]